[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui nord stream 2 un
projet gigantesque de gazoducs au coeur
d'une véritable guerre énergétique entre
les états unis et la russie
en effet alors que la russie temps de
terminer sa construction au plus vite
les états unis la pologne et les pays
baltes cherchent à tout prix à lui
mettre les bâtons dans les roues
quel est donc l'état des lieux dans ce
bras de fer économique mais aussi
diplomatiques le 20 octobre les états
unis étendent les sanctions contre north
stream 2 désormais toute entreprise qui
livrent des services ou du matériel pour
la poursuite du projet risque de se
retrouver sur la liste noire américaine
pour moscou ce n'est rien d'autre que de
la concurrence déloyale la majorité des
membres de l'union européenne accuse
washington de violation du droit
international
cependant les pays baltes ainsi que la
pologne et l'ukraine a que la décision
américaine abrazo verts pourtant
washington ne s'arrête pas aux sanctions
et semble être plus que jamais
déterminée à évincer le gaz russe de
l'europe en février 2020 mike pompéo
annonce un financement à hauteur d'un
milliard de dollars en soutien à
l'indépendance énergétique des pays
d'europe centrale et de l'est
une initiative censée rendre le gnl
américains plus attrayant
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur ce projet de gazoduc russe
qui cristallise les tensions entre
washington et moscou
c'est le bit actuellement deux ans après
le début de sa construction nord stream
2 est terminé à 97 %
ce sont en réalité deux lignes de
gazoducs qui franchissent les eaux de la
russie de la finlande de la suède du
danemark et de l'allemagne sur une
distance de 1200 km son objectif est de
doubler les capacités de nord stream 1
en fonction depuis 2011 il devrait donc
pouvoir acheminer quelques 55 milliards
de mètres cubes de gaz en europe
chaque année le coût du projet s'élève à
quelques 10 milliards de dollars
il est financé à moitié par le géant
russe gazprom et l'autre moitié est à la
charge des sociétés européennes comme
royal dutch shell om vlj une hyper et
winter choc nouvel obstacle à la
réalisation de nord stream 2 en octobre
washington annonce un volet de sanctions
qui visent plus de 120 entreprises
européennes impliquées dans le projet
une décision que moscou qualifie de
raquette politique
ces sanctions ne font pas l'unanimité en
europe les pays baltes et la pologne
ils sont favorables alors que le reste
de l'union européenne dénonce une
violation flagrante du droit
international
washington explique ces mesures par la
défense de ses intérêts nationaux mais
aussi ceux de l'europe
selon les autorités américaines le
nouveau gazoduc risque de rendre le trop
dépendante du gaz russe
cependant en adoptant des restrictions
contre north stream 2 l'administration
trump promeut activement son propre gaz
naturel liquéfié en europe et insiste
sur l'augmentation des exportations en
février mike pompéo promet un milliard
de dollars aux pays d'europe centrale et
de l'est afin qu'ils réduisent leur
dépendance énergétique à l'égard de la
russie une autre occasion pour renforcer
les pressions se présente avec
l'empoisonnement présumé de l'opposant
russe alexeï navalni
le président américain appelle
publiquement lieu à rejeter la
construction du gazoduc
alors comment la faire navalni at elle
influencé la position européenne sur
nord stream 2 comment la russie comptait
achever la construction du gazoduc
et enfin quel est l'enjeu économique de
nord stream 2 pour l'europe pour
répondre à ces questions nous rejoignons
samuel furent farhi professeur de
géopolitique de l'énergie à l'université
libre de bruxelles
monsieur furent farhi bonjour bonjour
bonjour à toute l'équipe et à tous les
spectateurs ravis de vous recevoir
tout d'abord pourquoi nord stream ii at
il rencontré tant d'obstacles dès le
début même de la part des pays européens
c'est parce que il ya encore des
réminiscences de l'ancien régime
je n'irai et on se méfie encore dans un
hôpital de la russie faut pas oublier
que ce qui s'est passé en ukraine et
anti mais laisse des traces des deux
côtés d'ailleurs est donc là il ya
toujours un peu de suspicion
qui à mon sens n'a plus sa place dans la
nouvelle configuration du monde
nous sommes dans une situation
énergétique totalement différente de
celle du passé mais c'est très difficile
à enlever de notre tête
les diplomates sont encore souvent dans
le paradigme d'avant mille 2014 et ils
réfléchissent comme en avant 2014 il
c'est pas possible c'est pas facile de
d'appuyer sur le contrôle à l'élite
parce qu'on est dans un autre système et
donc voilà j'espère qu'un peu à la fois
on va comprendre que nous avons
abandonné le vieux paradigme énergétique
nous sommes dans un nouveau système où
il y a abondance d'énergie et nous
aurons tous besoin d'énergie et au lieu
d'avoir des confrontations comme nous
avons eu dans le passé il faut aller
vers des coopérations en matière
d'énergie pensez-vous que l' affaire
navalni qui a éclaté récemment puisse
enfin de compte influencer la décision
des pays européens sur nord stream 2
dans un futur proche je ne le porte pas
un sou c'est un phénomène est évidemment
très important je ne minimise pas la
crise que cela occasionnait mais je
pense que ce projet north stream
transcende tout cela faut pas oublier
que ce projet a été porté à bout de bras
par l'allemagne
c'est l'allemagne qui a voulu ce projet
le nom seul un a été poussé par l'ancien
chancelier parce que je faisais qui est
toujours impliqué d'ailleurs
personnellement dans ce projet c'est
quand même un signe très fort de
l'intérêt de l'allemagne disposait et
encore maintenant
l'allemagne a abandonné avant de les
sortir projet donc la ferme à vannes me
vient perturber
on va trouver des solutions des
compromis mais l'allemagne ne peut pas
abandonner ce projet et comment
voulez-vous que l'allemagne fonctionne
en disant qu'elle abandonne son charbon
en abandonnant son l'énergie nucléaire
elle va quand même pas fonctionner avec
des énergies éoliennes au faut être un
peu sérieux
le la gagnant e ne me investis nommément
en matière de des aliens mais les élèves
ne représente que 3% de l'énergie
primaire de l'allemagne
et le solaire invités 3%
donc tout ce que les régimes ben duffy
pour l'instant représente 4,4 pour cent
de la demande en énergie
faut pas exagérer quoi donc le reste ça
ça bien sûr du gain c'est l'allemagne un
peu le soir du gala
or elle n'a même pas encore un terminal
gazier
donc l'allemagne a besoin du gaz russe
premièrement ensuite le gaz russe
une fois qu'il est en allemagne il va
être diffusé et ailleurs aussi
l'allemagne doit devenir un hub du gaz
russe
il va devenir un lieu de transit
ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'il ya des
autres galas du petit écran un conflit
comme local pour acheminer ce gazoduc
vers vers l'europe centrale c'est un peu
paradoxal non
que le gaz passe par la mer baltique
pourrait tourner ensuite vers l'europe
centrale
donc non je pense que l'avenir du nord
stream va se poursuivre je ne vois pas
pourquoi j'avais abandonné merci
beaucoup monsieur furent farid
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci
le 20 octobre le département d'état
américain étant les sanctions contre le
gazoduc russe nord stream 2 washington
compte ajouter sur sa liste noire toute
entreprise qui participent de près ou de
loin au projet assureurs banques
autorités portuaires ou fournisseurs du
secteur de maintenance de bateaux si
elle n'arrête pas à leur contribution à
nord stream 2 d'ici un mois leurs fonds
seront bloqués aux états unis l'accès au
marché américain alors sera interdit et
leurs employés ne pourront plus franchir
le sol américain selon l'opérateur du
gazoduc la société nord stream 2 âgées
cette mesure risque d'affecter plus de
120 entreprises européennes
cette décision américaine déclenché une
vague de critiques de la part des
autorités russes
malheureusement cela fait déjà partie
intégrante de cette concurrence
ouvertement déloyale de cette
concurrence sous forme de racket de la
part de washington
pourtant ce n'est pas la première fois
que washington tente d'arrêter la
construction du gazoduc
tout commence par de simples menaces
début 2019 l'ambassadeur des états unis
à berlin
richard grenelle envoie des lettres à
plusieurs sociétés allemandes les
menaçant de
sanctions en cas de soutien au projet de
gazoduc nord stream 2 décembre 2019
washington joint le geste à la parole et
adopte un volet de sanctions contre
toute entreprise aux personnes liées à
la construction de ce gazoduc
à ce moment là il ne reste que 160 km à
construire côté allemand les
restrictions comprennent le gel des
avoirs et la révocation des visas
américains pour les entrepreneurs liés
au gazoduc
pourtant washington refuse de dévoiler
tout de suite la liste des entités
sanctionnées leur donnant ainsi la
possibilité d'arrêter les travaux et
échapper aux sanctions
c'est notamment la voie choisie par
l'une des figures clés du projet aussi
société suisse propriétaire du plus
grand navire de pose de pipe lines au
monde
dans l'immédiat elle annonce la
suspension de ces travaux provoquant
ainsi un retard dans l'achèvement du
projet néamoins mousse coin dit
clairement qu'elle terminerait ce projet
par ses propres moyens
l'achèvement du gazoduc prévu
initialement pour début 2001 est donc
reportée au début 2021 tout cela
provoque l'indignation de l'allemagne
principal bénéficiaire de nord stream 2
le gouvernement allemand rejette ces
sanctions extraterritoriale elle affecte
des sociétés allemandes et européennes
et constituent une ingérence dans nos
affaires intérieures
mais les états unis ne sont pas d'accord
avec cette interprétation de leurs
manoeuvres
bien au contraire il affirme défendre
les intérêts de l'europe
selon les autorités américaines le
nouveau gazoduc risque de rendre
l'europe trop dépendante de la russie
qui contrôle déjà plus d'un tiers du
marché gazier européen et washington
craint que moscou ne puisse en profiter
pour y renforcer son poids politique
d'un côté et fragilisé l'ukraine de
l'autre car avec nord stream 2 une
partie du gaz qui passent actuellement
par l'ukraine seraient redirigés vers la
mer baltique privant kiev d'une partie
des droits de transit la russie quand
elle voit bien ailleurs la raison
principale des sanctions américaines
et si les sanctions se maintiennent il
ne reste qu'un seul motif lequel
qu'aucun offrir un avant
compétitif à son gnl à son gaz naturel
liquéfié
pourtant les états unis ne cachent pas
leur ambition de devenir le leader
mondial dans le secteur énergétique
c'est pour cela que parallèlement à
l'augmentation de la production du
pétrole et du gaz donald trump cherchent
activement de nouveaux marchés pour les
produits énergétiques américains en
juillet 2018 le président américain
accueille jean claude juncker à la
maison blanche est même si les
discussions étaient centrées
principalement sur la guerre des tarifs
trump aborde aussi la question des
importations du gaz naturel liquéfié
exigeant de l'europe d'en acheter plus
depuis cette rencontre
les exportations du gaz liquéfié
américains ont augmenté de 700 60%
néanmoins pourra-t-il vraiment faire
concurrence au gaz russe compte tenu des
inconvénients qu'il présente d'abord le
prix le gaz américain coûte presque deux
fois plus cher que son concurrent russe
en raison de sa liquéfaction et du
transport par bateau vers l'europe
l'autre problème et son effet néfaste
pour l'environnement car la fracturation
hydraulique largement utilisé par
washington pour extraire le gaz engendre
la pollution des eaux et des sols selon
berlin le gaz issus de cette méthode
d'extraction a exactement le même impact
écologique que le charbon
alors qui soutient la construction du
gazoduc russe et qui s'y opposent en
quoi consiste l'utilité de ce projet
pour l'europe
par quoi nord stream ii at il commencé
et quels obstacles ont retardé sa
réalisation
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
après deux ans de travaux et de
négociations de tout genre nord stream
ii est en phase finale pourtant le
gazoduc sera t'il terminée vers le début
2000 21 comme le prévoit le calendrier
compte tenu de la pression accrue de la
part des opposants à ce projet c'est
dans les années 2000 que la russie
commence à multiplier les projets de
gazoducs en europe
à ce moment la voie principale de
transit du combustible bleu passe par
l'ukraine
or la société russe gazprom accuse de
plus en plus souvent l'ukrainien
naftogaz de soutirer illégalement du gaz
destiné à l'europe
les désaccords débouche sur plusieurs
scandales autour de la dette ukrainienne
liées au gaz ou encore des conditions de
renouvellement des accords
parallèlement les besoins énergétiques
de lieux ne cesse de croître
sur ce fond gazprom anthem en 2005 le
projet nord stream 1 réalisée en
consortium avec des sociétés allemandes
françaises et néerlandaises
ce gazoduc d'une capacité de 55
milliards de mètres cubes par an devient
opérationnel en 2011
pendant sa construction en 2009 la crise
gazière russo ukrainienne éclate
faute de paiement est d'accord sur les
prix gazprom cesse de livrer du gaz à
l'ukraine kiev se sert alors dans les
stocks de gaz destiné à l'europe ce qui
prive plusieurs pays de chauffage en
plein hiver pour éviter que cela se
reproduise
moscou décide de développer des projets
supplémentaires de gazoducs alternatifs
ennuyeux la priorité est initialement
accordé à south stream qui devait relier
la russie et la bulgarie à travers la
mer noire or sa réalisation est mise à
mal par la commission européenne qui
multiplie des obstacles légaux dès 2013
alors que la construction était déjà
commencé le projet est gelé côté bulgare
en 2014
sur fond de crise des relations russo
européennes n'est alors l'idée de nord
stream de gazprom se charge du projet la
viabilité
économique du 'pipeline' est confirmée
dès février 2014 commence donc la
recherche des investisseurs européens
qui est achevé en un temps record le
début de la construction est annoncée en
juin 2015 lors du forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg et l'accord entre les
futurs actionnaires aient signé trois
mois plus tard nord stream 2 devait
ainsi être détenu par gazprom à 50% et
leur est distribué entre les allemands y
aune et winter scholl l'autrichien omv
et le néerlandais royal dutch shell et
le français angie le projet soulève
immédiatement une vague de
mécontentement chez les pays qui
touchent des dividendes pour le transit
gazier via la route ukrainienne c'est en
premier lieu l'ukraine elle même mais
aussi la slovaquie et la pologne
sans pouvoir obtenir le blocage du
projet à bruxelles varsovie inflige par
elle-même une première claque à nord
stream 2 elle bloque en 2016 la
candidature de sociétés européennes pour
l'entrée dans le consortium avec gazprom
en fin de compte le format du consortium
est remplacé par un investissement
collectif par près laissant le géant
gazier russe
seul propriétaire légal du gazoduc au
même moment les etats unis sont en
pleine révolution de schiste qui a pour
résultat une production accrue de gaz de
schiste - propre et transporté sous
forme liquéfiée
il est plus cher que le gaz russe mais
ouvre quand même la voie aux aspirations
américaine sur le marché européen en
août 2016 l'administration obama se
prononce pour la première fois contre
north stream 2 mais c'est sous donald
trump que cette opposition commence à
prendre des contours légaux en août 2017
le congrès adopte la première loi
pénalisant tous les investissements
étrangers dans le gazoduc
or les sanctions ne sont jamais mises en
oeuvre à cause de l'indignation
européenne contre cette intervention
inacceptable
les sociétés investissent eux européenne
bénéficie alors d'une immunité
washington choisit alors une autre
stratégie et déploie une vaste campagne
de lobbying au sein de lieux
l'itinéraire du gazoduc passe par la
zone économique exclusive de la finlande
de la suède et du danemark
malgré la pression américaine les deux
premiers délivre les permis à nord
stream 2 puis le danemark cède à la mi
2010 8 c'est le seul pays à ne pas
encore avoir donné son aval à north
stream de la construction commence quand
même mais doit bientôt s'arrêter devant
la zone économique danoise
l'autorisation n'arrive qu'en octobre
2019 forçant gazprom a repoussé
l'achèvement du projet entre-temps des
amendements à la législation gazières
européennes entrent en vigueur
voulue par les opposants à nord stream 2
elles interdisent à gazprom d'être
propriétaire du gazoduc et à utiliser
plus de 50% de ses capacités sur ce
front là aussi la bataille judiciaire se
poursuit le sort de nord stream 2 est de
plus en plus incertain le gazoduc essuie
un nouveau revers fin 2019 les états
unis lancent une nouvelle attaque qui
pénalise toutes les entreprises
européennes qui participe à la
construction de nord stream 2
le jour même le suisse holcim chargé de
poser les conduites suspend toutes ces
opérations
gazprom se charge lui même du chantier
en envoyant sa propre flottille pour
terminer le tronçon restant malgré de
nombreuses pressions américaines les
pays européens résistent
l allemagne passe à la contre attaque le
gouvernement allemand entend achever le
gazoduc north stream 2 malgré
l'opposition des états unis
nous considérons les sanctions
extraterritoriale des américains comme
et illégitime avec la production
européenne de gaz en baisse l'allemagne
mise sur le gaz russe pour couvrir ses
besoins énergétiques croissants et
d'ailleurs en europe sa voix n'est pas
la seule à défendre
nord stream de notre tâche primordiale
est assurer le transit de gaz à travers
la république tchèque
nous soutenons donc le projet north
stream 2 en effet le gazoduc russe
apporterait de très gros volumes de
transit et donc de gros dividendes aux
tchèques et aux allemands en effet
parallèlement un hors stream de
l'allemagne termine la construction de
son pipeline
gales qui devra distribuer le gaz russe
vers le reste de l'europe comme le fait
actuellement
opale pour le gaz a mené par nord stream
1 au gal se terminera donc en république
tchèque
d'où le combustible transitera en
autriche puis en slovénie et en italie
pays de transit potentiel l'autriche
fait évidemment partie des défenseurs de
nord stream 2 les pays bas sont dans le
même camp ils protègent leur entreprise
qui compte parmi les principaux
partenaires du projet 5 milliards
d'euros telle est la somme déjà investi
dans ce projet gigantesque par les
sociétés européennes une implication que
la diplomatie européenne ne peut pas ne
pas défendre par principe l'union
européenne s'oppose à ce que des pays
tiers recours à des sanctions contre des
entreprises européennes exerçant des
activités légitimes les politiques
européennes devraient être décidées ici
par les européens et non par des pays
tiers n'est un mois au sein des
vingt-sept les opposants au projet
restent nombreux parmi eux la slovaquie
et la hongrie
car avec nord stream 2 cpie avec le cren
perdront une grande partie des
dividendes que le rapporte le transit
gazier actuel qui passe à travers le
territoire ukrainien
pour les autres la motivation serait
plutôt politique non stream-2 consolide
le pouvoir russe aide le président
poutine à renforcer son armée aide à
intimider d'autres nations
la pologne est sa rhétorique antirusse
pourquoi est elle à l'avant garde
une fois de plus c'est que depuis
quelques temps varsovie se distancie de
plus en plus de bruxelles politique
migratoire des accords économiques et
autres les points de tension sont
nombreux
et lorsqu'on se tourner vers les usa on
tourne automatiquement le dos à la
russie le 7 octobre l'autorité anti
monopole polonaise turquie qu on pose
une amende record de 6,5 milliards
d'euros à gazprom est de 5 ans 2
millions d'euros à cinq sociétés
européennes engagées dans nord stream 2
en plus le au kitsch ordonne d'annuler
leur contrat en rapport avec le gazoduc
la raison selon varsovie les six
entreprises ont violé les règles
européennes sur la concurrence elle les
intéressé réfute ce verdict et décide de
faire appel
en effet le montant des amendes et la
légalité même du jugement fait hausser
les sourcils
jusqu'à bruxelles des tentatives
d'empêcher la construction de nord
stream 2 qui se soldait jusqu'ici par
des échecs cuisants avant que la sphère
navale line viennent jeter de l'huile
sur le feu fin août
l'opposant russe rentrer de sibérie à
moscou
il fait un malaise dans l'avion
atterrissage d'urgence à omsk navalni ne
sort pas du commun après des examens
approfondis sa famille obtient
finalement l'autorisation des médecins
de le transférer pour soins en allemagne
contre l'avis des médecins russes berlin
déclare aussitôt que navalni a été
empoisonné par un agents neurotoxiques
sans fournir de preuve publique
pourtant le kremlin est vite à mener
contre son gré a joué sa réputation dans
cette affaire qui prend des ampleurs
considérable ses détracteurs eux jouent
la carte de nord stream 2 les nouvelles
sanctions sont envisagées avec elle les
menaces de porter un nouveau coup fatal
au projet pour la première fois
l'allemagne n'exclut pas de le
sanctionner
une idée qui est pourtant assez vite
abandonné le monde entier ne peut pas
être réduit à l'incidence malheureuse de
l'empoisonnement de monsieur navalni
l'union européenne réussira-t-elle à
trouver un équilibre entre ses intérêts
commerciaux et les dissensions
politiques comment résistera-t-elle à la
pression croissante des états unis
finalement non stream 2 at il des
chances d'être achevés à temps pour y
voir plus clair nous revenons vers
samuel furent farid professeur de
géopolitique de l'énergie à l'université
libre de bruxelles
monsieur france paris imaginons que
le nouveau président des états unis
s'appelle joe biden quel est l'avenir du
coût d'un hors stream ns je ne peux pas
dire avec précision s'il va se changer
évidemment monsieur weidmann avait une
attitude très différente celle de
monsieur tron sur les énergies fossiles
du moins dans son discours une fois
qu'on y sera au pouvoir
on verra jusqu'où il ira je voudrais
rappeler que le gaz américain à gaz de
schiste s'est développé sous la
présidence de monsieur obama lorsqu'il
sait pas elle était vice président donc
il va pas mettre à la poubelle c'est pas
possible
donc il va continuer à avoir un intérêt
pour son gaz américains et qu'ils y
at-il derrière l'opposition américaine
au nord c'est à bien sûr il ya les
réminiscences de la guerre froide
surtout du côté des des du sénat avec
des républicains dans l'ancien paradigme
mais il y a aussi la volonté d'aider les
entreprises américaines à vendre du gaz
en europe et en particulier à
l'allemagne
donc je crois que il ya toujours cette
volonté mais va-t-il aller aussi loin
que monsieur trump en imposant des
sanctions va peut-être pas je crois que
quand même il y aura à la fin le bon
sens qui va revenir parce que on
n'avance pas on dort on l'interdît pas
de vendre quelque chose à quelqu'un dans
un monde où il ya de de la concurrence
et un monde ouvert monsieur ferrari
pensez vous qu'il ya une alternative
aujourd'hui au gaz russe en europe y at
il une autre source d'énergie que ce qui
serait aussi concurrentiel sur le marché
alors ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
que le gaz naturel est hyper abondant
bien entendu la russie reste le premier
pays en matière de réserves de gaz et
pas loin on trouve l'iran et brial kata
donc une piña trois grands pays qui font
à peu près 45 % des réserves mondiales
15 partout où pensez qu'aujourd'hui il
ya du gaz en israël et israël veut
exporter du gaz
donc quand même un phénomène tout à fait
significatif on va importer du gaz en
europe en australie
on va importer du gaz est également du
mozambique
bref le gaz est hyper abondant dans le
monde ce qui veut dire que le marché va
devenir fluide et dynamique grâce au
transport par par méthaniers et le cette
nouvelle situation fait que le gaz russe
va être en concurrence avec les autres
gars tu bien entendu le coût de
production du gaz en russie est très bas
et donc la russie encore beaucoup de
levier beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
pour revendre son gaz en europe en
jouant sur le prix mais s'il le s'il
devait y avoir des tensions belle
l'europe s'approvisionneraient ailleurs
et c'est ça que les gens ne veulent pas
comprendre c'est que qu'ils ont toujours
peur en disant oui mais si on importe où
le cadre de russie ou mettre des
pressions géopolitique s'est terminée
cela ya plus de pression géopolitique on
peut acheter du gaz et du pétrole
n'importe où dans le monde aujourd'hui
on est passé d'un marché de support est
à un marché de demand et donc c'est
celui qui veut acheter le gaz qui décide
c'est pas lui ce n'est plus celui qui
veut le vendre et donc dans ce système
je crois que la russie a très bien
compris que elle peut continuer à vendre
du gaz à son voisin et européens sur
cette question de coût tout simplement
normalement le langage riche en moins
cher le gardien australien
merci beaucoup samuel furent farhi je
rappelle vous êtes professeur de
géopolitique de l'énergie à l'université
libre de bruxelles merci d'avoir été
avec nous d'avoir apporté votre analyse
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]